[Music]
very well send a raven north tell Jon
Snow that if Queen invites him to come
to Dragonstone and bend the knee
Siddharth and I will ride for white
Harbor tomorrow then sail for
Dragonstone
[Music]
hey guys in the second episode of the
season we find the near skimming an
interesting meeting with Melisandre that
resulted with her inviting the king in
the north to come and meet her
upon welcoming Melisandre to Dragonstone
the mother of dragons and the red
priestess shared quite an interesting
conversation on the nurses question
regarding the Lord Of Lies expectations
of her know Sandra said the long night
is coming only the princes promise can
bring the dawn Melisandre said his
sentence on high Valyrian and the nears
translated it into the common tongue
replying with I'm not a prince
however the conversation was interrupted
by miss sandy who highlighted that
Daenerys translation is not quite
accurate since that noun has no gender
in high Valyrian and the proper
translation for that prophecy would be
the prince or princess who was promised
to bring the dawn upon being asked by
Danny veteran as she sings the prophecy
refers to her no Sandra replied with
prophecies are dangerous things I
believe you have a role to play as does
another the king in the north
Jon Snow Tyrion was seemingly surprised
after what she said and agrees with no
Sandra to summon Jon to Dragonstone as
he could be a valuable ally asking about
him Daenerys learns of his role as the
king in the north
and orders Tyrion to write the letter to
John asking to come to Dragonstone and
bend the knee while Jon wasn't sure
whether or not to leave Winterfell for
Dragonstone once he received Sam's
letter in which sense states that
there's plenty of dragonglass on
Dragonstone islands as it's been
expected Jon realized that he has to
lead the north for gemstone Tyrion is
invited me to dragonstone to meet with
Daenerys and I'm going to accept
we need this dragonglass my lord we know
that dragonglass can destroy both White
Walkers and their army we need to mine
it and turn it into weapons even though
the northern Lord says those sense of
stark disagreed with his decision John
is aware that North needs powerful ally
in order to stand a chance against the
night King and his vast army and
therefore he knows that meeting with
Daenerys is of the crucial importance
beside an area sent her three dragons
being of the great importance in the
time of war there's also mounting of
dragonglass beneath the dragon stone
which is decide illyrian still the only
known substance capable of killing White
Walkers Klaus kills White Walkers it's
more valuable to us now the goal we need
to find it we need to mine it we need to
make weapons from it well denier still
tried to persuade John into pledging his
forces to her cause in order to defeat
Cersei Lannister Seven Kingdoms will
bleed as long as thirsty sits on the
Iron Throne join us together we can end
her tyranny John on the other hand will
try to convince her that the real threat
is not Cersei but rather the night King
John will try to persuade the nearest
single sending her armies and dragons
north but more importantly we need
allies the knight king's army grows
larger by the day we can't defeat them
on our own
we don't have the numbers Daenerys has
her own army and she has Dragon Fire I
need to try and persuade her to fight
with us in the last episode the king of
the north end RC word for company bit a
few soldiers left Winterfell for white
Harbor the main seaport of the north
very firm they will set sail for
Dragonstone at the preview for the third
episode confirmed that long-awaited
meeting will finally take place John
will meet Daenerys promotion photos for
the Queen's Justice which is a title for
the third episode of the season can
recently been released and besides using
a huge meeting it has also confirmed one
or even two reunions the first one is
obviously a reunion between John and
Tyrion who bonded in the first episode
of the very first season while another
reunion would also include John but
surely would not be as pleasant as the
first one the king in the north end
Davos will arrive at the shores of
Dragonstone in the very beginning of the
upcoming episode and will be greeted by
Tyrion and miss sandy even though
reunion between those two characters
will be formal at the hand of the
Green is welcoming the King Jon Snow I'm
very excited and looking forward to
conversation that those toodle most
certainly have while being at the same
location in the first season those two
shared quite a few conversations and one
of Tiryns quotes that he said back then
turn out to be very helpful six seasons
later all dwarves are bastards in my
father's eyes I think it's really caring
it could be someone trying to lure you
into a trap
read the last break the dwarves are
bastards in their father's eyes
what does that mean if something you
said to me the first night we met
however upon being greeted John and
Davos will be escorted by Tyrion
ascending into the castle or more
accurately into the Dragons control room
to meet Daenerys another reunion is not
these nor confirmed but it might have
been hinted by new promotional photos as
well as by one of the official trailers
there's a photo of Eris whispering
something into the nurses ear which
might be various informing the nurse
about yars fleet being intercepted and
destroyed by your own Greyjoy however I
believe that Varys is rather informing
his screen about the single robot filled
with a few surviving greater soldiers
arriving at their shorts including Theon
himself which would also mean that their
fleet has been destroyed from the
official trailer we know for sure that
the young will arrive at Dragonstone at
some point of the seventh season taking
into account that you're unwilling the
very next episode arrived at King's
Landing with his prisoners see and
arriving at Dragonstone doesn't seem to
be out of the realm of possibilities if
you're wondering why would they receive
four in the nearest about either of
those two possibilities that I mentioned
a few moments ago by whispering is
because Daenerys is having a meeting
with John Snow at that very moment
Jon Snow being a Dragonstone and Theon
on the other hand arriving on the chores
seems to be a good time for another
reunion which will not be as pleasant as
a reunion between John and Tyrion
there's also a photo in which we can see
Melisandre being approached by various
from the official trailer we know that
no Sanjay will be watching over Jon Snow
in Davos while those two are being
escorted into the castle which means
Varys will join Melisandre few moments
later since it seems to be the same spot
other Nando's photos from Dragonstone
there's also show that includes great
warmth during the attack of Casterly
Rock
in the last photo we can
similarly in the citadel in this video I
will provide an answer on a very common
question regarding Arya Starks really a
meter long lost are bulimia which is of
the meaning of arias parting words as I
predicted in one of my previous videos
regarding Arya reunion between currents
what spy resulted with Arya finding out
the truth about the rise of House Stark
as it's been expected upon finding out
that her sibling or took Winterfell and
the judge has been proclaimed the king
in the north
Arya changed her oath and is now heading
north to Winterfell rather than south to
King's Landing Arya chose to reunite
with her family with the pack rather
than being on her own rather than being
a lone wolf in order to survive and most
importantly to protect her family
however even though her second reunion
was expected to happen as well it didn't
go quite well
while Amelia did say aria from her pack
she didn't join Ari on her way home as I
was saying arias parting words that's
not you caused the confusion among the
fans and even though many of us
suspected it was a callback to season
one
it's recently been confirmed by the
showrunners long story short in the
fourth episode of the very first season
there's a cinema Chanel tells his
daughter that one day she will be a lady
and will get married to powerful Lord
and which re replies with no that's not
me can I be Lord of a holdfast you will
marry a high Lord and rule his castle
your son's shall be knights and princes
and Lords
absolutely one of the showrunners David
Benioff says Atari wanting me to come
back home with her and be her loyal
companion again but the media's found
her own life Ben his collaborator he
devised on the other hand underlies the
ned stark's call back saying that's not
you is a direct reference to what ari
herself said to her father and her
father painted this picture for her as a
lady of a castle and marrying some Lord
and wearing some frilly dress
Arya is not domesticated and it makes
total sense her wolf wouldn't be either
one of the vol folks away at first she's
heartbroken to have come disclosed then
she realizes the wolf is doing exactly
what she would do if she were dead
wolves new media does have a new life as
she's a leader of a pack of wolves but
I'm sure she will appear once again in
the era of greatest need in conclusion
those new promotional photos is a huge
meeting between the king in the north
and the mother of dragons as well as the
reunion between John and Tyrion it also
might have hinted the reunion between
John and Fiona's I believe Eris is
interrupting a huge meeting by informing
his clean about Theon's arrival the
shores of Dragonstone but I leave it to
you to decide whether or not this
predictions show anyway Queen Daenerys
will demand to the king in the north to
bend the knee and pledge his army to her
cause while John on the other hand will
try to convince her that the real threat
is not served sea but rather denied king
and his army and as always let me know
your opinion about all of this in the
comment section down below
I hope you guys enjoy this video if you
did please make sure to subscribe to his
channel and I hope to see in the next